There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
This month, I tested out a lot of products
from Simihaze Beauty.
This is a new brand for me,
so let's start with the stuff I liked.
The Solar Tint blush duo comes with
a cheek pigment and a cheek gloss.
These both went on really easily,
and the pigment is so good.
Surprisingly, I loved
the cheek gloss more,
even though it's not super
practical for all-day wear.
I didn't love the color
of this Velvet Blur
matte lip balm on my skin tone,
but the formula itself was so good.
It has the comfort of a lip balm
but the pigment and blurring
effect of a matte lipstick.
It's creamy and super comfortable.
I thought the Lunar lip gel
and the Super Slick mini
lip balm were just OK.
The lip gel was pretty,
but the formula was nothing special.
It's just a thin lip gloss.
The mini lip balm was pretty moisturizing,
and the tint is cute,
but it's so little
product for what you pay.
Again, nothing special.
Now for the products I just didn't like.
I wanted to love the Sun
Flush all-over face tint,
but it just ended up being really patchy
and broke up my foundation.
And I tried this a few different ways
to see if I was just applying it wrong,
but it still messed up
my foundation underneath.
The Easy Lash Clean Lift mascara
just didn't do much for my lashes.
I didn't get much lift,
I got little to no volume,
and my lashes weren't
lengthened very much.
Overall, I love the
packaging of this brand,
and it does have some standout products,
but I think it's all very overpriced
for how the actual formulas perform.
Everyone has been raving
about the Summer Fridays Lip Butter Balms.
This set with the minis
is limited-edition,
but they sell all of
these shades in full size.
I ended up really enjoying these.
The formula is on the thicker side,
but not sticky.
They feel really moisturizing,
and I like how they give
an almost lip-gloss effect.
I loved all of the tinted balms,
but I think Poppy was my favorite.
They all give a pretty,
subtle wash of color,
and they have this nice vanilla scent
that's not overpowering.
I'm obsessed with these.
This is the Danessa Myricks Beauty
Lightwork IV Transcendence palette.
I'm not gonna lie,
I was very intimidated
by this palette at first.
It has four different formulas:
velvet chromes, which are
color-shifting powders;
pressed chrome flakes,
which are flaky toppers;
glass metallics, which are
super-reflective powders;
and aqua chromes, which
are water-activated
duo-chrome pigments.
So there is a lot going on.
I started applying over a light wash
of black eye-shadow base to
make the colors pop more,
but I don't even think
I needed to do that,
because these powders are so pigmented.
I was determined to use all
of the different formulas,
so I added one of the
metallics in the inner corners
and put the chrome flakes in the center.
The flakes were the only formula
that was a little difficult to work with,
only because they're kind of
hard to pick up and apply,
but I think they added
a really cool texture
and color shift to the eye look.
I used an aqua chrome for some eyeliner,
and it's so reflective and sparkly,
and it dried down quickly.
This palette is extremely pricey,
and I did get some slight fallout,
but the quality is definitely there,
and I think it's so much
more versatile than it seems.
The shades in here are so transformative
and really inspire you
to play with your makeup.
Plus, it can also be used on the face.
These are the L'Oréal Colour Riche
Intense Volume matte lipsticks.
I thought these were going to be similar
to the Nars Powermatte
lipstick I tried a while ago,
but the formula is different.
The color payoff on these is so good,
and they apply really smoothly.
This is one of the most
comfortable matte formulas
I've ever tried, especially
from the drugstore.
What makes this lipstick
different from the Nars one
is that it's unfortunately
not transfer-proof.
To be fair, it claims to be smudge-proof,
so it's not the same thing.
Regardless, I think these lipsticks
are comfortable on the lips,
and the colors are so rich,
so I really like them.
Apparently Gwen Stefani
has her own beauty brand
called GXVE, and this is
the first product from it
that I've ever tried.
This is the Double Dippin'
2-1 lip color remover
and hydrating lip mask.
I wanted to test it out with
my Nars Powermatte lipstick,
since it's one of my
hardest-to-remove lipsticks.
The formula of this lip mask feels
like a makeup-removing cleansing balm.
If you've never tried one,
they feel really oily.
Because of that, it actually
broke the lipstick down really well.
It made it super easy to remove.
However, as a regular
lip mask, it just feels
way too oily and thin to be comfortable.
This just feels like one of those products
that they market as multiuse
to make it sound more innovative.
Lights Lacquer just released
its winter collection,
called Cocktail Hour.
I do own a lot of their polishes,
so this isn't a new brand for me,
but I definitely think this is my favorite
color story they've ever done.
The polishes have those wide, flat brushes
I love for applying.
It just makes it so
much easier and faster.
I tried the cream shades,
Old Money and Audrey, first,
and both were full coverage in two coats,
and the application was really smooth.
Then I tried the jelly
shade, called Lady in Red.
Because this is a jelly,
it's way more sheer than a cream,
so I ended up doing two thicker coats
for full color payoff.
The color is slightly lighter on my nails
than in the bottle, but
still pretty and so shiny.
Next I tried To the Nines,
which is a metallic polish.
I really love this color,
but this formula is
probably the least forgiving
when it comes to streaks and bubbles.
My two absolute favorite
shades from the collection
are Whiskey Neat and Diamonds Are Forever.
Whiskey Neat is also a metallic formula,
but it's more of a duo-chrome,
and Diamonds Are Forever
is like a milky taupe
with a bunch of superfine glitter in it.
I don't think these colors
separately are anything new,
but I love how they all work
together in this collection,
and the formulas are all so good.